Spider-Man's fighting the Avengers and
the ending of this story is gonna blow
your minds it's amazing check this out
so what this does is this initially
picks up with Spider-Man being
confronted by The Avengers now one thing
I want to specify here this is The
all-out Avengers miniseries we already
covered the Doctor Doom one you'll find
a link to it pinned in the comments
section this one and the Doctor Doom one
of the only good ones so that's why
we're only covering those the other ones
are yeah they're okay but what what
Peter Parker talks about here is how the
Avengers minds are being controlled by a
person called the Grand manipulator now
the overarching theme when it came to
all-out Avengers is that someone
somewhere was doing something that was
changing reality itself we didn't fully
understand what was going on but it was
changing things right so that's why in
the Doctor Doom one you basically had
Doom who was split into two versions The
Super Evil one and then just like the
good doom and then when they re-emerge
we got normal Doctor Doom again Peter
Parker picked up on that but what's
going on here is that things have
suddenly shifted because Peter picked up
on the idea of the grand manipulator and
basically the person pulling the strings
here and so what's kind of funny here is
that each of these groups acts fairly
normal the only person that seems a
little off here is Thor and it's kind of
intriguing because of course when he
greets Peter Parker it's just like
Spider-Man give us the contraption if
your friend deactivates it improperly
it'll scramble the minds of every person
in New York City including yours I like
your mind it is amusing sometimes
annoying but mostly amusing but by and
large what Peter's talking about here
and what Thor's talking about here there
was a device that was created that would
basically undo the mind control of
seemingly all the Avengers here and of
course there's a scientist that Peter's
working with in order to solve that
problem the issue here is that with the
Avengers trying to get their hands on it
they immediately attack him now of
course Iron Man's the first one up and
Peter Parker takes out Iron Man like
that in the blink of an eye now here's
one of the things that I love about this
comic Peter Parker is arguably one of
the most slept on characters in Marvel
Comics in popularity yes he's the face
of Marvel right you'd have to leave the
planet Earth to find someone or an alien
race that's never heard of Peter Parker
and even then there's probably aliens
out there that are reading Spider-Man
comics right he's just that love level
of popular but in terms of what he's
capable of this guy is an absolute Hoss
and it's all because of his Spider Sense
combined with his intelligence and so
when Iron Man steps up Peter's able to
take him out because remember ever since
the events of Civil War Peter has had a
grand understanding of how Stark Tech
Works how his suit works because Tony
Stark gave Peter Parker an Iron Man's
suit of his own the iron spider suit and
so of course following the defeat of
Iron Man or at least a temporary
deactivation of Iron Man's suit Jennifer
Walters steps in who cares so after
Jennifer Walters ends upcoming Carol
Danvers right now the Carol Danvers
fight is an interesting one because
truth to tell I would never argue that
Peter Parker could normally overtake
Carol Danvers in a knock down drag out
hand-to-hand fight it's just not gonna
happen his Spider Sense would allow him
to like Bob and weave and Dodge but he
just doesn't necessarily have the actual
ability to overtake and to defeat Carol
Danvers and that's why what he does here
is he actually just keeps her at Bay he
ends up slipping up hill in her mouth
that actually just kind of Spurs out a
bit of webbing that temporarily
incapacitates it right like literally
leaves her choking now he says it'll
dissolve in 60 seconds which doesn't do
much help because you could suffocate in
less time than that so Peter Parker
potentially just killed Carol Danvers
which is kind of a crazy thing but once
he makes his way into a building what he
ends up doing is coming face to face
with blade now this is a fight that you
rarely ever get to see and I'm not even
gonna lie to you guys we're probably not
gonna get it but I want to see a fight
between Spider-Man and blade in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe so here's a
question that I have for you guys right
leaving out the plot necessity of this
story for Peter Parker to overpower
blade in a knock down drag out fight
where there is no pre-written conclusion
right we won't actually Know How It Ends
who do you think would win in a fight
between Spider-Man and blade who do you
think would really win like I'm really
curious because honestly my money's on
blade but of course Peter Parker ends up
getting the upper hand on blade himself
what ends up happening is that when
Peter Parker starts to get the upper
hand on him black panther jumps in right
t'challa jumps in now what's
disappointing about this is we don't
actually get to see a prolonged fight
between between Spider-Man and Black
Panther because that would have been
amazing but the reality here is that
even though black panther is able to
momentarily gain the upper hand Peter
Parker of course is able to Bob and
weave Dodge out of the attack and then
he's ultimately caught up to by Captain
America now of course once he throws one
of his webbing grenades right and like
incapacitates the entire team he again
takes off and that's what he's caught up
to by Thor but with Thor getting a piece
of his shirt Peter Parker is able to
make his escape and then kind of take
off and go into hiding this is kind of a
cool moment because one of the things to
remember is that they all have to rely
on their naked eye in order to find
Peter Parker and so of course he
basically jumps forward right he's
ultimately caught up to by Iron Man yet
again and we we get a little bit of a
solution here in finding out that the
way Peter was able to take down Iron
Man's suit was by using a bit of a disc
and so ultimately he's instructed right
like hand over the re-sequencer you have
no idea what's gonna happen if you
activate this thing which he gladly does
and that's when The Avengers realize it
all happened too quickly now the
undercurrent here and the thing that's
not actually established and this is
something that I love Peter Parker
literally said he just kind of LED them
on a merry Chase which really indicates
that Peter Parker actually gave these
guys the benefit of the doubt he wasn't
really even going all in and what this
really points to is the idea that if
Peter Parker were fighting against the
Avengers and he were fighting to kill he
would destroy them all and there's
actually Merit to this right there is a
legitimate story where this more or less
happened it's an alternate reality story
and the circumstances were a little bit
different we covered it you'll find the
link to it down in the comments although
yeah I'm pretty sure we remastered it uh
that is a story where Peter Parker
basically Kills the Marvel Universe it
was amazing it focuses largely around
Punisher in the aftermath of it all but
it's cool it's a really really cool
story like Iron Man dies in his suit his
suit shuts down so he's trapped in it
and he can't get out and he just starves
to death or or dies of dehydration but
it's like he was screaming in his suit
for three days and nobody could get him
out like that kind of a thing it's it's
kind of wild there have been credible
stories out there where Spider-Man has
demonstrated the ability to take out the
entirety of the Avengers the other part
of this is that the reason he let him on
a Mary Chase is because he was basically
just buying time he already already gave
the resequencer the real resequencer to
the Grand manipulator he already has it
and by the time the Avengers figure it
out and by the time they get there the
resequencer has already been activated
and everything just kind of goes back to
normal but here's the funny thing about
this once they get in there they all
feel like they're normal selves they all
feel like things are just the same way
they always work nothing feels like it's
wrong and so what Iron Man does is that
in the middle of this whole fight he was
downloading video footage throughout the
city and having a suit automatically
filter through to find specific points
in time and he presents this data to
basically the entirety of the Avengers
team as it exists there now in one of
the previous videos that had happened
basically Spider-Man has seemed to
succumb to some kind of mind control but
so did The Avengers it's not a really
important thing but it's a little bit of
a thing there what this video footage
basically shows is they were both mind
controlled both groups were being mind
controlled at the same time more so than
that whatever was going on here with
this person's ability to manipulate
reality what they were doing is they
were altering the time stream at the
same time so you basically had two
versions of reality happening
simultaneously now once they realized
they had all been tricked that it was a
giant Rouge where they had all been
duped that's when they end up figuring
out that the grand manipulator is none
other than the scientist Dr Samuel
Crassus that Peter Parker's been working
with and handing the resonator over to
now the funny thing about this is that
when Peter asked him are you the grand
manipulator his response is I tear
reality asunder right now right off the
bat that should tell you what's going on
here and who this person is but again
the ending this is going to be crazy so
what ends up happening here is that once
they start to realize they'd all been
tricked and their grand manipulator was
this doctor well then we get a bit of
just convenience right like kind of
convenient storytelling where Peter's
like actually here's the thing I didn't
fully trust you in the first place and
so I made a few changes to the uh to
this whole resequencer and basically it
wipes this guy out of existence or at
the very least it just kind of seems to
destroy his Essence right so it's just
kind of a husk laying there he's
basically dead right Peter Parker kills
this guy and it's kind of a funny thing
because this happens just for the sake
of being able to wrap up story not the
most important thing but what is
important is the voiceover that we get
the monologue that we get right this
voice says that worked out rather well I
think they were just getting a little
too close I need them to figure it out
sure but on my time jumping ahead of my
schedule could ruin everything but I
think this will do it I just have to be
more careful in the future more subtle
these are smart people after all for
humans and so we transition over to
Captain America now here's the thing
Captain America is oftentimes his
intelligence is oftentimes overlooked
he's exceedingly capable so this
highlights just how smart Captain
America is right he says hello he walks
into an empty room and he says hello and
he says I know you're there I can't see
you but sometimes I think I can feel you
I know you're watching this was clever
giving us a bad guy a new villain who
can take all the blame for everything
that's happened you couldn't have us
asking too many more questions could you
who knows where all that speculation
might have led us so you gave bus the
grand manipulator and immediately the
possibilities narrowed but it was too
little too late you'd already made your
mistakes why was that the more it went
on the more you had to change the harder
it was to maintain control is that it or
did you just get sloppy you're listening
to me you're paying attention if I were
Emma Frost or Charles Xavier I might
even be able to see you right now but I
don't need psychic powers to recognize
your power and I'm coming for you
beyonder that's right ladies and
gentlemen the beyonder is back in Marvel
Comics he's technically been back since
since Defenders Beyond but we didn't
know where he went to he's manipulating
everything behind the scenes because
remember what Defenders Beyond establish
is that there is a threat out there that
is more powerful than the one above all
more powerful than God and it's coming
and it's only a matter of time before it
gets here what the beyonder seems like
he's doing is manipulating things to
prepare the superheroes to get them
ready for this insanely powerful threat
which honestly I don't even know how
Avengers on a singular Earth defeat a
being more powerful than the being who
created everything in existence but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace